I could ask you the dumb and you could
say well I don't feel like dancing and
then I could say well maybe some other
time
[Music]
or I could just not on your future life
we're talking about you hardly know him
he's practically a stranger the thing is
I just know this is it I'm not feeling
Toby people paralyzed by polio don't
last long can't move anything from the
neck down
can't even breathe for yourself
how do you live like this yes Jesus I
love you and I want Jonathan to know you
you can't yes yes I can there must be
something I can do Hospital no one else
disability exists outside a hospital
where has anyone ever tried robbing
Robin oh my god much better
five pounds says never make us you're
wrong
darling cool tell you I've had an idea a
wheelchair that does his breathing for
him are you sure it's safe it's white so
far Helen you owe me five pounds I mean
as 30 why do you keep your disabled
people in prison no one's leaves as
possible to live as you do well we
should open the gate and set him free
bloody viable up in a well thought
wouldn't that be an adventure when I
first became paralyzed I wanted to die
my wife told me I had to live
yeah uncle your life is my life I don't
want to just survive
I wanted truly live
[Music]
I love I think he should be in hospital
no you're quite right No
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you